today i'm going to show you how to make
a homemade face moisturizer for dry skin
now the thing about dry skin is that
it's not a dehydration situation it's
not that you're not drinking enough
water that's not it in fact the more
water you drink
the drier your skin is going to be
because you're going to dilute your
electrolytes okay so dehydration creates
a lot of symptoms but it's typically not
dryness of the skin
dry skin is low efa what does that mean
essential fatty acids okay and i'm
talking about
an unsaturated fat not saturated fats
omega-3 fatty acids now
essential fatty acids are both omega-3
and omega-6 but the reason why i'm not
going to talk about omega-6 is because
chances are you already have too many
omega-6 fats in their diet corn oil
soy oil canola cottonseed oil and we
really are deficient in the omega-3
fatty acids and so when you don't have
enough of this your skin gets really dry
and flaky there's actually three types
of omega-3 you have epa
and dha but you also have a precursor
ala all right that can turn into epa and
also dha to a certain degree and these
omega-3 fatty acids actually protect the
skin
against the sun it's rays like uv light
so they do a lot of things for your skin
not just keep your skin moist but they
can protect against uv radiation now how
do you get omega-3 fatty acids well from
sardines
cod liver cod liver oil fish oils like
salmon
algae things like that
but are you gonna really rub sardine oil
or cod liver oil on your face right
probably not a good thing now you could
rub algae in your face but what i'm
going to recommend in this video is
using chia seed and seaweed okay
so this is simply how you're going to
make this facial mask which is then
going to give you the result of more
moisture in your face okay so you'll
combine six teaspoons of water in a
little container and two teaspoons of
chia seed ground down we want to grind
them up to
release some of these oils all right
and then we're gonna add a teaspoon of
seaweed you can either get
seaweed as a powder or you could take a
seaweed tablet from a supplement and
open up one of the capsules or you can
get some dry seaweed from a little sheet
and crinkle it up and put it in a
teaspoon and add that to it and then
we'll add one teaspoon of olive oil make
sure it's extra virgin olive oil the
real good stuff we're gonna mix all this
up
we're gonna apply this to our face okay
and then we're gonna wait 15 minutes and
then we'll wash it off now you're going
to find that the omega-3 fatty acids in
the chia seed as well as the seaweed
directly goes in the skin anything that
you put on your skin gets absorbed
because all these chemical moisturizers
that have petroleum products alcohol
chemicals that they're putting on their
hands or their face it's going right in
like a sponge so you really got to be
careful about what you put on your face
so it's very similar to foliar spraying
like spraying nutrients on plants it
goes right into the leaves the same
thing with our bodies
now i do want to point out this is a
quick fix okay
obviously you want to find the real
cause of why your your skin is dry in
the first place and you do want to start
consuming omega-3 fatty acids in your
diet okay and also isolate other reasons
why your skin might be dry it could be
that you're a smoker or you're getting
second-hand smoke or you drink too much
alcohol or
consuming too much sugar or you're going
through too much stress which can
greatly affect
your skin and as a side note to that
you have all these friendly microbes on
your skin that are supposed to be there
so if you're using certain types of
cleansing
creams or cleansing lotions to strip off
things from your skin to clean it you're
also destroying the friendly microbes on
your skin
and that can create dryness or
irritation or redness so
stress can can affect the microbes on
your skin
and not having enough microbiome or good
bacteria in your gut for certain reasons
let's say for example you took an
antibiotic
that can also affect your skin from the
inside out so there's a lot of different
reasons why you might have dry skin it
could be that you're on the typical
american diet where you're consuming a
lot of seed oils corn oil soy oil canola
cotton seed oil which are very high in
omega-6 fatty acids that will literally
create a deficiency of the omega-3 fatty
acids this is actually very common or it
could be your soap is drying out your
skin there's a really interesting video
that you should watch on soap
the tap water
from the shower okay you're getting
exposed to fluoride and chlorine which
is very very harsh on your skin you
should get a filter and if you wear
makeup or certain foundations and has
petroleum in there or alcohol that can
create the drying out effect but a
really good video for you to watch next
if you haven't seen my one on soap
is the one in soap check it out i put it
right here